the fella said that it's early in the
morning for them to sing but they'd be
willing to do december for us which is a
great song wonderful song man it's
really good
give us a little something before we uh
go into what i don't go into the new
stuff i'll give you some michael you
like echo
yeah check it out check it out
all right guys come on let's do a little
december uh favorite of mine
[Music]
because he just says you think
[Music]
just told my son to what you told me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we don't scream about
think loud will turn you away now baby
just spit me out don't worry about it
don't speak of dope we'll turn you away
now baby just spit me out
[Music]
[Music]
as you swear
[Music]
don't throw away your basic
[Music]
don't scream a belt
don't think loud or turn your head now
baby just spit me out don't worry about
don't speak of death we'll turn your way
now baby just spit me out don't scream
and felt and don't think aloud or turn
your head now baby just spit me out
don't worry about
you
me out
[Music]
oh
very nice